[Music]
[Music]
that's right
we're back all right
keep it going yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
keep it going
human trafficking immigrants
keep it going for doxy
doctors
let's go God damn we are back in the 20
uh billion dollar Studio actually
funneling weapons to the Ukrainian Army
this week that's right ladies and
gentlemen we are all domestic terrorists
I like that none of those things uh
because what is the YouTube terms and
services like you can't say anything
like shaky in the first 30 seconds or
whatever can't drop like a F-bomb yeah
yeah but but you can say all of those
things oh yeah no we know what we're
doing yeah you know exactly what we're
doing guys we're back we've been gone
for two weeks because Hassan uh found
better things to do for the two weeks
obviously doesn't care about America or
he would have been here but that's fine
yeah I was I was selfishly doing other
stuff which is ironic because like I
didn't even realize that I actually had
time to do leftovers and I and it's my
fault I last second would be like hey by
the way I realized like I'll be back
earlier than I expected yeah so we can
shoot it and then at that point Ethan
was like no I'm gonna you know be in the
metaverse sorry dude you know we move
fast yeah he was like no sorry plans I
made 2D friends like my bad
um yeah well anyway we are back we have
a lot to talk about first of all I want
to say how hello to my tater tots out
there what's up top geez we're gonna be
talking about politics you guys are
gonna love this one not support me you
[ __ ] little [ __ ] baby boys shut up
wait wait it's just haircuts if you want
to give the tater tots jump scares
you're showing me for a second like Bill
I don't know if you can yeah hey Tater
thoughts get a load of this worst
nightmare
what's up the real talk Gene the real
adult G by the way by the way this is
not a I I just I can't believe that we
are in a 20 billion dollar compound and
how janky the multicasting stream set up
here is is unimagined real that's what's
good about it this reminds this
literally reminds me of like when I
first started streaming uh off of a
PlayStation Eye like a PlayStation
camera when I was playing fortnite to
like 15 people look you make it shitty
to encourage the people to come watch
the real program yeah on YouTube that's
brilliant thank you yeah uh okay so
here's the deal guys
uh first of all top of the show I just
sorry Hassan I know I just got to
promote this real fast uh this just came
out 19 minutes ago it's live on Teddy
fresh goddamn.com
this is the 100 recycled piece this is
the piece I'm wearing right now that is
right I'm gonna get you this the sun you
want this right yeah I like that dude
how nice is that that's cool we call it
it's kind of a special Technique we have
it's called watercolor brushed tie-dye
oh that's hot
yeah it's dope I've never seen that
before really thank you yeah no I it's
it's very good I like the teddy first
one in the middle too between the two
Cardigans yeah that one's look that one
I'll get you that one uh anything else
for you live here there's a question let
me think I'm gonna point to some things
you're gonna say it's for women only
let's try Okay uh I like that Polo
t-shirt this one yeah that's for women
oh that's crazy okay uh let's see let's
do you like this one with the Pug on it
oh what the hell I already I I have a
lot of do I have too many crew necks for
women well I do like it though I like a
lot it's just I have too many clothes
these beanies are fire I I can't wear
beanies anymore I have long hair I love
that really it's one of the worst
wow that's messy oh you do like that
okay I'll send you one no that wasn't me
um I uh what else I like I like the
pants like the dance the carpenter ones
railroad denim carpenter pants
yeah yeah these these I can get you oh
really what's your waist size uh 38 boom
right there 38 you got that Lena
she's not for women only no no no that's
crazy that's what you mean look at that
boom and then um
oh wait what is a cross stitch pleated
trousers wait click on that let me see
that which ones are oh here the black
one yeah yeah these are these are you
are for men they're pleated [ __ ] yeah
they're pleated bro okay I want those
two I'm I'm pleading with you please
take a peek come on oh I want those as
well all right and then this one also
Danny writing that down to 38. I got it
I'm sending tween right now all right
thanks beautiful all right there it is
teddyfresh.com I put I gotta put I gotta
make sure you get something out of these
plugs you know this is original art by
the way don't hurt my feelings of course
it's wonderful which uh we all
can uh
relate can't we folks
all right so I love the QVC music in the
background when you do this
you know this one's going yeah this
one's flying off the shelves Folks Gotta
Get Him in the mood
all right so first of all
um
you I just got to get right into it
because there's a lot of stuff I want to
talk about one is the gambling slash
I don't even know how else to call it
there's like a whole
sexual harassment controversy yeah
there's um another big story I want to
talk about is that Republicans are
trying to get uh doctors killed yeah oh
really I mean they've done it before uh
George tiller I believe is yeah uh
famous famous case from Bill O'Reilly
yeah he was murdered outside of an
abortion clinic right in like uh house I
think but he was a he was a doctor that
was facilitating abortions at the time
yes so uh Matt Walsh and Tucker Carlson
have been it's kind of insane these are
doctors that work at um
children's health clinics that yeah
children's hospitals and they do help
young trans kids with therapies and
procedures and stuff so the real
villains of society children's doctors
yeah yeah I mean I'm always thinking
about that I'm less than that more Mount
Walsh's yeah yeah Society
yeah more liberal arts Majors who sit in
front of a [ __ ] camera and and cry
about [ __ ] endlessly including myself by
the way don't don't misunderstand I'm
saying we're not exactly providing value
uh speak for yourself but anyway
um I have a lot of value oh thank you I
know my worth uh wait why is the title
of this his song got called out well
we're getting to it oh wait what not
it's nothing it's the xqc stuff oh I
just did it catchy I just I just saw it
I'm like what I needed a catchy title
ass grifter dog [ __ ]
are your response to that that's the xqc
talking about Hassan what is wrong with
you [ __ ] I love when he says
[ __ ]
off my face man
get the balls off his face that one that
one is really good
um yeah yeah so I don't know why he said
that anyway there's they're they're like
showing the face of these doctors and
where they work they're really really
genuinely trying to get them killed and
then the other one is as DeSantis
kidnapped
um like 70 of Venezuelan immigrants and
flew them to Massachusetts for some
[ __ ] reason so there's there's a
whole lot to talk about but the first
thing I want to get into
is uh the twitch gambling thing because
I've been
I've been watching you and like I've
been losing my [ __ ] mind now I don't
know if you saw me talking about
yesterday
I didn't I didn't want to watch it
because like you had a tall long-haired
white guy on oh is that making you
jealous and it made me very much better
I'm assuming you're referring to
this picture yeah it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] you said you never kissed me
like that well yeah we can you wanna do
a camera you want to do a camera
maybe this was a lot for me I'm not
gonna lie it was not it I'm not ready to
give you a peck yeah I need to reach
back oh you ready for young gravy but
not me but we were yeah no I just need
to recharge maybe maybe on like a
Christmas wow I'm sorry that these lips
have not touched Addison Ray's mom okay
that's the difference oh [ __ ] that is
what it is yeah I I basically ate out a
thousand MILFs in that moment yeah
that's crazy my bad dude I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm not slaying like [ __ ] maybe
I just need to recharge okay maybe on
Christmas okay maybe mistletoe we'll
have a mistletoe moment
that could be good yeah I can't be
kissing all these dudes I mean I am
married
true
um
so
uh all right well let's just talk about
because I I was getting so angry because
of course you're right about everything
you said and the way that train wreck
and xqc like I mean gas lit which is not
a word I ever used but they really did
they cornered you and Pokey and forced
you guys to [ __ ] like
apologize for some dumb [ __ ] and I'm
just so [ __ ] I'm just I just pissed
me off that's good but like I think he
had a follow-up the next day too like
I'm trying to move away from that as
best as possible because I was like I
wanted the like my immediate reaction in
that moment was
okay this is ridiculous train wreck is
not like a reliable person when it comes
to stuff like this he always pops off
about like the Illuminati following him
or whatever I've known him for many
[ __ ] years you know and it's
completely unrelated they're talking
about gambling while Pokey and I are
having a conversation about gambling on
the platform
um and he's like responding to uh miskiv
calling out one of his like earlier
scams I think I think he he might have
had like a rug I don't even know
anything about them Yo you did a jolt
coin you know what's crazy about
joltcoin we've been doing a lot of
research on that and somehow train wreck
has scrub or I don't know him or someone
else scrub the [ __ ] internet of that
[ __ ] I spent like two hours digging all
over the Internet last night for
anything about Joel coin wasn't it glink
that did that originally yeah and you
know he his video is gone yeah every
link every tweet gone everything on the
way back machine scrubbed it's like you
scrub stuff you can like dmca it
whoa so they these guys they may have
even hired like a you can hide
everywhere I looked it was a [ __ ]
dead end that's incredible that there
was no
backups I mean this is the internet how
rare is that bizarre yeah I've never
seen something like that so apparently
he did a rug pull which obviously
doesn't surprise me apparently uh
allegedly uh called jolt coin but
whatever so miss Kiff was like yo you
did a jolt coin thing and then he was
like well you covered up a uh he popped
off saying something that was so vague
and so unrelated to the main point of
contention there that of course every
single person that looked at it went
what the [ __ ] like he said
where are the yeah if I can if you can
pull up the original tweet like he
basically implied that like Mischief may
or may not have like sexually assaulted
multiple women and then blackmailed them
by using his girlfriend at the time Maya
and like his his friend Mitch Jones to
cover up all of those things and
everyone was like what the [ __ ] all
right so here you guys are having a
conversation about gambling and then
train wreck goes
uh whatever this they're arguing and
here he drops this he goes are you going
to send Maya and Mitch to Railroad and
blackmail me like you did those girls
cover up all those sexual assaults
you [ __ ] scumbag piece of [ __ ] you
want to come at me and make [ __ ] up then
you better sure make sure you don't live
in a glass house you insecure [ __ ] now
first of all my main point of contention
is that the way he brought this up and
weaponized it and a way to serve his own
purpose in fact xqc literally even admit
on stream he's like yeah this is a
weapon and we were holding it out like a
trump card I mean it's disgusting these
guys are giant pieces of [ __ ] the way he
introduced this is entirely [ __ ] up
and I know that the girl
the victim supports him and she says she
thinks it's fine and my point is like
I'm not questioning the validity of her
claims at all she's absolutely not yeah
and what I'm doing is just saying what
train wreck did I'm disagreeing with her
on this one point that what train wreck
did is completely [ __ ] up the way he
did it and uh he's a giant piece of [ __ ]
most people most people recognize that
though because like this is a very
delicate matter I think they try to
defend it by saying like oh we wanted
the most attention on it the most
eyeballs but it's like that's look how
we brought it up we brought it up
emotionally he brought it in a way that
was like I'm doing this bro this this
happened I'm doing this to [ __ ] you not
to defend her also like XTC and train
have some of the largest platforms like
Tran has uh around my size of an
audience uh xqc is much larger than
myself as well he's like one of the
largest content creators like they could
have just literally had her on either of
these streams to be like this is a uh
you know this wasn't easy to come
forward with but we talked to Adriana
and we decided like you know we're gonna
have her say her piece like that would
have been a hundred percent and it's
just another bad faith [ __ ] they go
we did this so we'll get more attention
so everyone's talking about and I'm like
no you didn't think about it this was an
emotional way to [ __ ] over mizkiff and
like you said it has done like but for
the record like this is not a defensive
miscuit either no I'm not not any
meaningful capacity because what we
found out afterwards is that there is
validity to what Tran was saying but my
immediate reaction when Pokey and I were
talking about gambling and while this
was happening was what the [ __ ] is this
so here's your reaction and again their
criticism or the or the 32 second one
that they were like hammering on
it's oh yeah this is the this is the one
that they keep like using as a gotcha
I've watched this clip and so one of the
things again they keep trying to
um deflect is they go oh you didn't take
it seriously enough and I'm sorry but
like
there's no other way to react than you
guys did when train introduced it in
this most [ __ ] up way possible I mean
are you going to send Maya and Mitch to
Railroad and blackmailed me like you
want those girls to cover up those
sexual assaults you [ __ ] scumbag
piece of [ __ ] you want to come in and
mix it up then you better be sure you
don't live in a glass house you inscript
I'm lost if he did this like an altruism
why did you call him a
why did he call him
a
sorry I'm just curious train if you
could explain this you did this in an
act of altruism so why did you call him
a [ __ ] scumbag piece of [ __ ] and also
uh insecure [ __ ] which part of that was
necessary
I mean it's understandable like if uh
I'm gonna be as charitable as possible
like it's understandable to feel uh
anger and resentment towards someone
he's not angry for the uh assault he's
angry about the accusation but it
doesn't matter there's no reason to make
inferences into like what is personal
motivations or what his personal
feelings are when like the delivery of
it is is a gotcha in a [ __ ] Twitter
argument and it serves his own purpose
and the actual accusation itself which
has well the blackmail side I don't
think has any validity or any truth
because I haven't seen anything about
that well um but but the actual like
um minimizing downplaying or at least
like having his uh friend which wasn't
even the original accusation but like
having misuse friend slick actually do a
sexual assault that part is true like
that is a legitimate thing as we found
out as we learn uh when Adriana came out
later a couple hours later and like
openly admitted on on a twitch stream
that she did
so
um the the way that he delivered it
however is is so uh it was so ridiculous
it's insane of course but you can play
the football yeah basically this isn't
the good clip I mean I've watched this
because it's fine I just want you guys
to see no no because I'm setting up a
lot here and a lot of [ __ ] I think it's
not about train wreck and I'm gonna
[ __ ] train I'm gonna turn him into a
train wreck because that guy is a piece
of [ __ ] and I'm [ __ ] covering him for
him today and I hope you're ready for
war Hassan okay because I brought blow
the horn
go ahead okay uh that's the war horn
dude you hear it let it [ __ ]
intoxicate you let your blood boil okay
from toe to finger Edge feel the
vibrations let's just wash this I look
I'm gonna do hey can we get a drummer
boy like you know revolutionary warship
like
like get that in there too Zach sorry
one sec
[Music]
I need some Drummer Boy [ __ ]
yeah you don't know you know what I mean
yeah yeah hold on
you know what I'm saying bro we're
marching off the war fix your bayonets
[ __ ]
we might wait till the white of their
eyes [ __ ]
anyway here as Zach pulls that up let's
watch this so again the context is that
they were turned it against you guys
saying you don't care about the victims
because your reaction is insane tweet so
let's just [ __ ] by the way are you
going to send Mom and Mitch to Railroad
and blackmail to me like you want those
girls to cover up those sexual assaults
you [ __ ] scumbag piece of [ __ ] you
want to come and mix it up then you
better be sure you don't live in a glass
house you inscript I'm lost I don't even
holy [ __ ]
are you going to send Maya Mission
railroad the black man like dude all
those girls cover up the sexual
Associates
then you better be sure you don't live
in a glass house you insecure [ __ ] I
literally just read it
the railroad him so she's laughing at me
rereading it yeah obviously after she
read it but they were trying to say like
Pokey is laughing at a sexual assault uh
case or whatever which is so disgusting
and so distant anyways they're [ __ ]
liars and they turned you guys they
Gaslight you guys into actually
apologizing for not reacting hard enough
they try to spin this as like uh you
know we're we're dismissive we're
dismissive yeah and like the longer clip
like five seconds after I'm literally
like I have no idea what the [ __ ] train
is talking about it's obvious I'm saying
people in my chat are saying like oh
this is like about crazy slick this is
about crazy slick I think and and like
they send me Adriana's tweets that are
happening simultaneously and I'm like I
don't know who this girl is but crazy is
a [ __ ] weirdo you know what I mean
like I don't know what's going on I'm
going to this is a serious acquisition
I'm gonna cover this later when I have
more information on it
so at that point that's what I said
um but for some reason that wasn't like
up to Snuff for their own initial uh
conversation like their own initial
liking and weirdly enough it quickly
moved away from the actual you know a
person the perpetrator in the
circumstance crazy slick or even like a
cover-up uh from Mischief right they
just like quickly shifted it over to
like me and Pokey you know why because
you guys were the ones trying to get
gambling banned yeah and they were
trying to [ __ ] deflect the whole
issue which is which is wild because
gambling did get banned crypto gambling
did get banned in the middle of that in
the middle of all of that unfolding well
you know why it happened because of that
video of train wreck literally bribing
twitch employees
in my opinion that's why yeah I I dude
that was my editor who posted that I
don't know I didn't even watch it I
never had time to let him look at that
but link that you got to see this but
okay okay listen listen hold on
because that's a that's also a serious
accusation but my own my personal thing
in that circumstance was I was covering
Puerto Rico uh which was underwater at
the time and I mean still is and I'm
covering that and people are coming into
my chat at this point constantly saying
like I had an involvement that I knew
and I was like a part of the cover-up or
some [ __ ] I'm like what the [ __ ] and
this is like tens of thousands of people
bro coming in and saying this so I I I
had no idea what the [ __ ] was happening
so I was like all right I'm gonna look
into this and also on top of that I'm
going to have Adriana come on if she
wants to because she was in my chat at
the time to say exactly what happened
which she did a person who's trying to
like dismiss or minimize the claims
would not do that which is [ __ ]
Preposterous but even after the fact
that I did that they still went on with
the narrative that I was like you know
dismissive originally I was dismissive
initially I was dismissive originally
and so was Pokey or whatever all the way
to like you know
uh yelling at me to a uh yelling at me
to like try to you know get me to to say
that I was dismissive and I was like I
was not so uh Pokey and I both
apologized to Adriana afterwards I was
like I'm sorry this was not our
implication this was not Our intention
but if it came across as dismissive in
the 32 second clip that you are you know
that everyone keeps uh posting and then
I apologize
um
and and basically that's that is what I
thought but they keep like bringing good
that up again over and over a serious
reaction they should have introduced it
in a serious way and by the way your
reaction was not not serious it was just
that of shock he is [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude yeah it was it was it was
frustrating and then I think xqc last
night was like well why didn't Hassan
debate her or something debate her if if
he if he was so serious I'm like I'm not
gonna debate what about the victim of
sexual assault about in front of 300 000
people when she's like
openly doing something that's like
already brave enough to just like come
out and talk about her traumatic
experiences why the [ __ ] would I what
are you insane like all right well here
now I've I put a lot of work into this
and I'm here today I have a thesis that
train wreck is the biggest piece of [ __ ]
on Earth that's my thesis here today and
I'm here to approve not just that but a
hypocrite
uh [ __ ]
disgusting human being and someone who
shouldn't even have a career I'll just
be honest he shouldn't even be I don't
think he's responsible I think no do you
okay I'm saying it all and I don't give
this guy's a [ __ ] Maniac he's a
menace first of all you haven't seen
this clip so here it is this is the
reason they banned gambling right here
bro watch it I know that's not the
reason it is we dude people have been
talking to Twitch for a long ass time
I've been like it just came down live
now I think the rain reason why they did
it is because they wanted a prw before
they got absolutely slaughtered a
Bloomberg article came about like child
predation happening on the platform on
the same day that they like in the
middle of the night release it they're
just gonna take more money from content
creators for no additional reason like
no benefits no extra you know goodies or
anything like that no new Services they
just said sorry we're taking more of
your Revenue because the platform is not
profitable enough for us by the way so I
think they wanted just a good I hope
they don't give YouTube any ideas
they did it on the [ __ ] same week the
YouTube announced that they're
monetizing shorts right it's crazy and
the shorts now you got 70 30 just like
the other [ __ ] that's that's what I'm
saying it's just bananas all right I'm
[ __ ] team YouTube but anyway this is
I believe this is why and you'll see
I think we're good let's get back to
this and let's wrap it up and then I'll
just gamble some more because I'm a
degenerate
getting that third one Joe I got 250
still on a trip
don't worry about it baby
I'll take care of YouTuber orange for a
minute I got you
for Pega fish are you kidding me bro
so this guy is that you want to stop
there's a developer at twitch okay
there's two staff dudes in his channel
the bigger fish comes in I give him 50k
leaves you can even stay for [ __ ]
five more minutes
Jesus Christ
oh he said no one's ever sent him
anything before Oh
no shots
I love that
no one has ever sent me anything before
oh relum that's so [ __ ] cute bro I
[ __ ] with that
yeah for real that's love really that's
a real [ __ ] that I love that role
no one is oh yeah there's music but we
didn't get it for last time but said
anything before that that is the
sweetest most sad thing ever isn't it
yeah isn't it sad that no one ever just
randomly gave you 50k in Bitcoin for
working out I mean dude he has so much
money he just he does he has a lot of
fun no he's just like constantly doing
this he's paying twitch employees that's
really sweet and sad hopefully he's not
like a hustler because I'm gonna send
him some more no take 30 take 30 000 all
together he just sent him 15 000 I sent
you two fifteen thousand two fifteen
thousands 30 G's realm do whatever you
want with that you know what I'm saying
if you want to walk into your the office
and tell your boss to suck your young
and [ __ ] off this is like um when Pablo
Escobar is like he's like yo I'm insane
I'm just [ __ ] giving money out to the
villagers
yeah um for the record twitch staff like
especially like low end you know random
twist Evers like I have a [ __ ] load of
them in my chat dude the real twitch
staff you don't actually see they're
invisible which staff yeah I mean I I
see that I'm just saying that like those
guys are not like deal makers on the
platform or anything you could have just
been like well that's what's going on
lacing them up front live on the stream
he's definitely buttering people up
behind the scenes too then bro no
[ __ ] doubt
um
I don't know I don't I don't think it
was like [ __ ] the bribing like
high-level Executives at twitch I doubt
that I think it was more so that like
gambling across the board is incredibly
profitable as an industry
and not only that but in the day that
twitch actually announced that they were
Banning crypto gambling.com yeah they
announced their partnership with
DraftKings for their NFL uh broadcast
for their NFL partnership so like that
was one of the main reasons why I was I
always said like I know that they're not
gonna ban the entirety of gambling I
know that that's not going to happen
um there's like skill based gambling
luck based gambling is a designation is
a distinction that they make it's still
all gambling it's still all luck based
don't misunderstand what I'm saying but
um they were never going to bend skill
based gambling as they call like you
know Blackjack uh and and you know poker
and and things like that of course but
uh they were never even gonna ban all
luck based gambling it makes sense that
they would only ban the crypto casino
because that has like no safeguards
whatsoever no consumer protection
whatsoever yeah so that was the tip of
the iceberg it was probably the most
impactful and the worst offenders
overall dude so that's why they went
after them huge difference in like
unregulated crypto casinos run out of a
shack in Curacao in DraftKings I mean
like there's consumer protection people
know it's legit everything that goes on
like DraftKings pays taxes they're
licensed I mean look gambling is one
thing so bad by the way I I for the
record I I have no issue saying this
like I think sports betting is bad like
Slicker literally [ __ ] stole all that
money because he was addicted to sports
betting so
um you know I'm I'm not in favor of that
either I think it's like ruining uh I
think it's even ruining like what the
what little Integrity it had but the
Integrity of professional sports
um but it's going to get worse and worse
I mean I'll tell you what when you
hostile when you put money in draftking
they [ __ ] make sure that you're of
legal gambling age oh yeah no that's
what I mean it's and I'm not even in
favor of banning vices in general for
the record I myself have gambled I go to
Vegas every now and then I gamble I've
talked about this openly
um I've even [ __ ] went to Vegas with
xcc and gambled as a matter of fact uh
it can be a fun thing that you're doing
if as long as you're doing it
responsible in the sense that like you
know you're going to lose a certain
amount of money that's the way I do it
unless and I am someone with an
addictive personality it's not for
everybody a lot of people don't know how
to control themselves I do not suggest
other people do it but
um there's a difference between that I
don't have a problem with draftking
because I mean look like you said it's
it's a vice we all partake in our own
vices my problem is with those
unregulated crypto ones you know what I
found out you know what you can do when
you're playing on you know I don't know
you can tell them hey ban me from the
site forever because I have a gambling
addiction yeah steak doesn't do that you
know what I found out what's that
apparently sports betting websites
literally cap you if you win too much
they stop you oh well there you go
that's no if you win too much oh I know
it's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] nuts they
got to make sure they always you know
the casino system is so fundamentally
broken like
um they they straight up
they straight up will ban you if you're
winning too much in sports betting if
you like know too much and you're
actually good at sports betting
um they will limit you to a degree that
like you can't even make any big big
bets any longer
um yeah my point always is there's
there's not exactly a whole lot of
safeguards when you're losing 100 of
your money but when you start making 100
return on your investment your profit
you're cheating you know then it's like
nope that's that's not allowed well
anyway
so moving on now to train uh this
Train's about to go off the rails okay
you know what I'm saying
I hope he brought a change of panties as
he wants a cold someone because this
shit's about to get [ __ ] up for him
now listen do we have the battle do we
have the little boy uh drummer role
please we had little boy
give me the this
yeah you said that's what you wanted bro
um
what
I know exactly I got you I sent Little
Drummer Boy Zach like revolutionary war
drum music where's the drama I don't
even hear drama these drums in there
play it turn it up
[Music]
this would be a British colony with them
here you go Ethan now play the horn
[Music]
put throwing the horn now we're talking
I don't think there's any symbols in
marching uh drums though
it's just one boy two sticks one drum
y'all I I have something I don't know if
it's copyrighted that's the thing you
hit me with it a little bit damn the
Revolutionary War Music would be [ __ ]
copyrighted that's crazy it's just a
little couple beats honestly I think the
founding fathers would have loved that
[ __ ] though hit me with that landowners
how's that
a drum roll Zach
a drum roll
Dan can you play what I sent
oh man I definitely I have no idea what
was wrong with the one I was playing
it's okay it had symbols
okay this is just this one this is
perfect just snare so there we go pure
this is one here
now this is what I'm talking about okay
now we're now we're off to work you feel
that song we marching
I'm sure now get a flute in there bro
oh my God
all right anyway enough of that stop it
thank you
uh so um yeah so trains accusing you
guys of not caring about the victim he
of course is a giant [ __ ] hypocrite
piece of [ __ ] because he has a
reputation for actually and I learned
this all last night and this blew my
mind because how could he be such a
giant hypocrite actually he has a whole
history of sexually harassing people and
are women and just being a disgusting
[ __ ] creep I mean I'm sure you've
seen these uh Hassan is that right I saw
I saw some of it I remember the what up
you sexy brown haired Latino because
like that was really funny when it
because
yes so um
these are all I guess chat logs of him
talking to women in their chat I think
this is specifically alinity who is a
content creator who at the time
um was not exactly well liked by the
internet she was like kind of a villain
like everyone considered it a villain
um uh so you know just the just the
center
the the mood around alinity at the time
so that people understand so he says
they're uh are you going to BlizzCon I'm
taking you to dinner if you are and
about what if it has to do with me it
couldn't be good I have big hands you
bad girl
face I'm taking you to dinner
what's up you sexy brown haired Latina
let's date hey hot stuff good for the
record for people who don't understand
this is like what uh train wreck is
writing in alinity's chat and it does
seem like there's a back and forth
conversation going on between him typing
in the chat and her responding I don't
have access to the vods or anything I
can't see
I don't know what she's saying in this
circumstance just but I will clarify
because a lot of people are not familiar
with how twitch works so just understand
because it does seem like he's talking
to her it gets worse and worse though
you'll see
and it seems obvious that she's uh
refuting his advances and to the point
where she well you'll see we're flying
you to California and we're going to
have dinner and hang out set your
schedule you dark hard sexy brown cute
accented person
I don't know if these are all to her or
what he says Hey Squad what's up damn
girl you're looking so good I had to
stop uh you've got man oh this is my
favorite she goes I had to stop my
sentence I would have gotten in trouble
no man she's 15. she's 15. trust me
that's why I'm into her damn I don't
know where what did what chats these are
from I don't know what the [ __ ] this is
from that's that's [ __ ] weird and
gross no man but if it's real because I
don't know what do you mean if it's real
where is it from who's he saying this to
oh you gotta you gotta have more
like we got to figure it out
right I don't know but I I think
somebody knows somebody somewhere knows
um
damn Mamacita you bad naughty little
mober I swear I'm gonna eat your wet
[ __ ] with your consent hashtag metoo
accused need to learn from this man what
uh he goes you look really good today do
you like sushi by chance uh damn we're
not into boys okay yeah guy uh let's see
he goes God you're bad Sophia I love how
you understand me one day I'm gonna have
a threesome with sko in you but it needs
to be in the dark because my [ __ ] is
small
he okay so here's what I'm gonna say
like
I don't know who these girls are that
he's talking to but I mean this stuff is
like
entirely up to the dynamic between him
and the content creator because like
everybody [ __ ] around in chat like
content creators [ __ ] around in the chat
of other people's all the time you can
like and out of context it can look
really bad and these certainly do this
one this is those tits look saggy and
ran through you're definitely an
attention craving [ __ ] Jesus Christ okay
um that one is definitely you know that
doesn't need additional context right
the part about alinity she makes it very
clear that he was
making her very uncomfortable all the
time yeah
um I think at the time this isn't uh
like it just it entirely depends on what
alinity says about the circumstance but
at the time I remember I think she said
something along the lines of like he was
being like he was like harassing me
regularly and I didn't like it
um
yeah
um but she also said like uh he
threatened to our word yeah her
and then nothing additional came of that
but I don't know if it was because like
at the time
uh everyone already hated her and were
like was like bullying her Non-Stop and
like you know she was not exactly a
favored person on the internet
um or because like there was nothing to
implicate that but I think train himself
said like that that back and forth was
Mutual at the time yeah this is not an
expensive train he's lying this is not a
difference At All by the way I just for
the for the record I just don't know
what the exact details were I'm just
like piecing this off of what I remember
yeah he's a liar he's a [ __ ] serial
liar so I mean that part is definitely
yes but I don't know you can tell by the
way that she responds to it
um but uh having said that like I like I
said it's entirely dependent on what
alinity says about the situation right
and she even wants to come out and say
anything at all because she might not
and this is it's totally up to her
that's the thing like
um
you know I I don't wanna I don't want to
like pull random people and be like hey
relive this uh you know traumatic moment
from your life and and draw
a [ __ ] load of scrutiny and ire from a
bunch of like random in cells on the
internet who are going to go back to
like uh hating on you because you came
out and said something you know what I
mean well what happened to alinity was
one of the things that really [ __ ]
pissed me off like at the time and even
especially now looking back I mean she
got
she got shafted so [ __ ] hard by the
whole internet
um it was honestly
repulsive disgusting and in the midst of
making serious accusations against train
wreck people were just basically
openly and socially acceptably victim
shaming her because she is uh not liked
and so but but I I have I'm not I'm not
I agree I don't I don't think she needs
to make any statements or anything I'm
just going off based of what
what uh she said at the time uh bring
extra underwear Hassan you're going to
be going through those quick around me
this is one that she posted here I'm
just gonna go down because uh
obviously right you don't know where it
came from
so here's one elity posted that he sent
to her um
here it is
he she he sent her this DM but she
explicitly says made her she is I was uh
she said I was mistaken exactly where
some of the threats happened it's been a
cycle of him sexually harassing me me
saying no him getting angry and
threatening me at events or in text then
later him wanting to talk it out only to
make sexual remarks or get in my face
again
and uh and this is the hey going to
twitchcon bring extra panties you'll
need them that's sexual harassment no
for sure that's [ __ ] disgusting no no
and she says it as uh she says it and
that that I think that that is like
pretty clear-cut I think that the reason
why this um I don't I don't remember
like why this didn't actually because
everyone hated her at the time and
trained and trains a Serial liar I mean
I've got it all here they go why'd you
cut off your response she's like here it
is he just said do you have Snapchat
yeah um so here let me go and you know
the reason I bring this up is because
um
train was going against you and Pokey
being like yo you guys don't care about
uh the victims like he's all of a sudden
the [ __ ] white knight for victims
this man is a
[ __ ] deviant who's been harassing
women to be fair for me
um this wasn't the reason why I was like
oh I don't trust train about this the
main reason was that I was just
legitimately [ __ ] confused because it
came out of nowhere that's not normally
how you would like reveal a potential
criminal accusations like this and not
only that but also I mean Trina does
have a history of [ __ ] posting
unhined [ __ ] about people following him
all the time and like you know people
just constantly out to get him he's said
that I have been out to get him for
years you know what I mean uh which is
wild because I usually just never really
talk about them
um and and then deleting tweets so I I
just uh you know there was that and it
was also the fact that it was like a
response in a random argument about
gambling so
um those were the main reasons but it it
but my intention as I've specified time
and time again was never to take away
from uh the the actual uh accusation
um which which came out afterwards not
with trains tweet but like the actual
legitimate accusation from Adriana and
her experience dude it's so obvious come
on it's like bad faith to even see it
any other way in my opinion
yes so going back to train and it is
really a travesty what happened to
alinity I think it's it's important to
like give Justice and light to what she
went through but here's the video she
said put out about train the champion of
victims everywhere uh here
the only person in this whole world that
I don't like
is trainwrecks yeah
it is him
I mean I think if a person tells you
that they're gonna rape you that's
something that's not cool you know it's
just not yeah
um
so I don't think I would ever want to be
alone with that guy ever I'm terrified
of him honestly
so
he's tried to hit me you know like he's
just been very aggressive towards me
okay so now what's interesting
is if you go around the internet
everyone says oh she walked the back she
lied about that okay now now that's not
what happened at all because actually
her what she walked back is this this is
what everyone refers to as her walking
it back I was mistaken exactly where
some of the threats happened it's been a
cellular homosexual harassment yeah
that's like that's that yeah that's not
her walking it back at all
I think
sorry I think that is this bore you
Hassan no I just like oh my God I didn't
are you not taking this video I'm not
being dismissed no that you're not
reacting hard enough I haven't I don't
know why I've been [ __ ] God damn it I
haven't been sleeping well for the past
couple of days uh
um
that's why I was like you know getting
Juiced up on gamer Subs okay um Nation
Bros right yeah [ __ ] man this happened
so [ __ ] long ago and I wasn't I
wasn't like on the platform when it
happened obviously I was you know I was
at the Young Turks so I don't really
know what the exact details are
um
but anyway the point is that people say
she walked it back and everybody refers
to this tweet it's not a walk back at
all like even if there is no even if
there's no like uh uh you know threat of
of our wording someone or a threat of
sexual assault or anything like that
like it is definitely
this is definitely 100 the sexual
harassment if she was you know clear and
and
consistent about being like dude I don't
want this and it does seem like she
didn't want it so
um here's what he said in response you
know and uh here at least he says Hey
guys some of you may have heard that a
twitch streamer made some serious
accusations about me on the stream
they're completely false and I'm
devastated someone make these baseless
claims I'm not sure if she just being
mean-spirited or said that Disturbed
drama for views but talking about it on
stream or making videos about it will
only bring the lies to more people's
attention at first she claimed this was
something that I had said to her then
later in the VOD she retracted that
backpedaled and states it in something
that I typed it in her chat years ago
the chat log proves otherwise the only
thing they show is what she's downright
lying and again the only reference to
her backpedaling is that tweet where she
was clearly not backbeddling he
continues it's sickening to me that
someone could slander me with a smirk on
their face like it's no big deal these
type of allegations have ruined innocent
people's lives before and should not be
taken lightly or isn't a joke I hope she
is punished accordingly so people will
think twice before trying to ruin
somebody's reputation for their own
entertainment
I mean so basically he's saying she's
doing this for her own entertainment the
irony of course uh is that he's saying
if you're familiar with the
case of the new girl uh I forget her
name the girl Adriana so Adriana he said
At first she said
uh it wasn't sexual assault Adriana she
said it was yes Adriana wrote a twit
longer the original actions happen at a
party in I believe January 2020. for an
entire year uh there was nothing had
been spoken about that it had not come
out to light at all as is the case in a
lot of these situations that's a normal
of course certainly a normal part of
this right so and then someone who was
friends with Adriana at the time
came out without her consent because it
was not her story to tell uh and and
openly stated that this had happened
right so Adriana uh from what I
understand at the time was like in shock
wanted to clarify wanted to clarify what
was going on so
um friends of Adriana
and Friends of uh Miz or Mrs girlfriend
at the time Maya went over to her house
to figure out uh what actually happened
that's
I guess that's the most neutral way of
of speaking about this but um the
Adriana's perspective on this matter
however is that they went there to uh
not clarify but necessarily I guess
to to suppress uh what what actually
happened right
right because the person slick was
living with Mischief at the time so
um they had a conversation about it the
people that were witness to the events
uh held the position that it was not
sexual assault at the time it was just
like oh I'm just checking her pulse I
think personally in a circumstance like
that when we're talking about like
groping or whatever it's at that point
it's entirely dependent on the
relationship that uh both parties have
with one another
um and the interpretation of the
individual which are which is subject to
change absolutely because like she was
not capable of giving consent so it's
clear-cut that it's sexual assault right
that he's like grabbing uh this person
without consent it is clear because
sexual assault but there's a difference
between
um you know
there's a difference between like two
people that are familiar with one
another which they weren't right and and
uh two people doing that to two people
that are strangers with one another
doing another one another but ultimately
it's still up to the victim to to make
that assertion
um at the time she wrote in a twit
longer
um after having this conversation with
uh three individuals one of which was
there and another person that was her
friend and another person that was Miss
Gibb's girlfriend after having a
conversation
um
she wrote that it was not sexual assault
like she clarified it in the twit longer
and I believe the reason was because
um they wanted to make the distinction
yeah they wanted to make the distinction
that she didn't think that it was sexual
assault so that people wouldn't know
that she told her if she didn't think it
was you know assault to write that yeah
yeah and would she by the way uh Maya
has apologized for that as well and I in
the conversation that I had with Adriana
Adriana said that like she appreciates
the apology so I don't know uh but that
again you know that it's a little bit up
in the air as to how that was handled
but
um because my herself has been victim of
uh sexual assault as well so
um you know
anyway
regardless uh that was a year after she
came out with a twit longer everyone
including people like myself who don't
know anything about these people at all
looked at it I said at the time
I said at the time
uh that it was really creepy and that if
circumstances were different if the
victim in that situation had said this
is sexual assault it's clear-cut sexual
assault the only thing that basically
absolved uh slick in that moment was the
fact that she said it wasn't sexual
assault in my opinion it wasn't sexual
assault yes or yes because she stated at
the time she didn't think it was and I
did so and and then for that entire year
since 2021 when it first came out when
she first came out with the twit longer
until this very moment she felt like she
was socially ostracized by that same
community of streamers as a consequence
of uh what she believes was crazy slick
personally and maliciously trying to
push her away okay and and I think that
that is one thousand percent True by the
way I do think with all the new
information that's come out about slick
and everything that he's done I think he
deliberately was trying to uh get
whoever he could to to you know not hang
out with this person he might not have
even [ __ ] told anyone what the
reasons were right but but because of
the original twit longer made it seem as
though there wasn't sexual assault and
because cause most people are completely
[ __ ] oblivious to how complicated
these sorts of uh these sorts of
situations are and rarely ever see it
from the victim's point of view
especially when it you know this is such
a common uh occurrence uh I think that
most people just like didn't even think
about it and they were just like yeah
let's just go along with it
um and and that was probably
additionally traumatic for a person that
uh now felt uh you know pushed aside by
uh her friends and and I think that that
was something that she was stressing a
lot that we haven't really talked about
as much and I I that that really
that really made it a lot worse
um for her
I
you know that and then and then you know
she came out and and spoke her piece so
so thank you that that's that's uh a
beautiful summary or not beautiful maybe
maybe a not beautiful summary it's just
good summary the reason I bring that up
is because train wreck this whole time
is like um
she changed her mind
and so but and so the first time but so
alinity is a [ __ ] liar for saying
that right
yeah I mean elenity that's what he said
salinity I would say said more
uh alinity had more serious claims than
even Adriana did but commercials to
another is like kind of weird too but
like I said it's entirely entirely up to
the to the victim to to come out but he
shows you know she's a [ __ ] liar she
needs to be punished she's doing this
for her own entertainment she's sitting
there smiling like he's painting this
picture like she's some sociopath and
he's saying that she walked it back and
she's a liar but in truth she never did
so he's doing this whole song and dance
about how he cares about the victims and
her story but at the same time
um no I think that I think the adequate
way of dealing with this at the time
would have been uh if train was as to be
as charitable as possible to train in
the circumstance is to be like I had no
idea that this was what was going on
um I'm so sorry for you know my words
and my actions being misinterpreted that
was not my intention at all when I said
you sexy brown haired Latina I thought
that those feelings were being
reciprocated if they were by the way in
any meaningful capacity as train claims
they were uh and that you know that he
is sorry for what happened but instead
he went on a [ __ ] Full Tilt you know
she's lying well when and when she's
already being [ __ ] on by the whole
internet he made it so much worse he
really painted her out to be like this
sick [ __ ] sociopath that needs to be
like buried she needs to be made an
example of he even says oh she's
punished
so nobody ever does this again for their
own entertainment it's like at the same
time uh he you know he seems to
understand that the influence of people
like Maya and mizkiff who he's claiming
influenced Adriana to not come forward
but yet he's doing the same thing to
alinity he's pressuring and threatening
her and dogpiling on her to keep her
from talking more about it he's doing
the same [ __ ] thing it's just
incredibly ironic
um moving forward
yeah that's my take on train wreck he's
a piece of [ __ ] dude he's a hypocrite
yeah and uh
honestly I believe elenity because
people always say she walked it back and
she never did she literally never did if
you read the Tweet she offered further
clarification switching it from
um I mean this is all we ever found in
terms of yeah and in terms of expanding
and people keep referring this as well
that's why I said like look it's just
it's entirely up to it's entirely every
single one of these instances the best
thing you can do is just make sure that
the environment is adequate for victims
to be able to come out there's nothing
else is definitely not doing that no he
did not do that and and you know 100
it's just entirely up to victims it's
not [ __ ] train wrecks it's not it's
not like uh it's not up to train wrecks
at all like that was what my original
frustration was it's like it's not like
hashtag believe women and train wrecks
it doesn't work that way it's not like
uh you know uh like you're not the one
who is the the resist that he put out
the claim anyway yeah so he's just such
a [ __ ] hypocrite bro and look at this
was her last statement so if we're doing
the same in this in this circumstance
it's again entirely entirely up to
elinity as to what she was to do she
wants to maintain or silence I 100
respect that
um
you know it's just yeah there's all this
stuff serious issues uh there's all this
other stuff but I don't even know if
it's worth it
like xqc
this I mean this is pretty funny because
again these guys are such scums dude I'm
sorry but I don't know if you're not
comfortable doing this but I [ __ ]
these guys just they're such pieces of
[ __ ] like here xqc says he knows nothing
about the alinity situation
uh but here's a clip wait where's the
original clip of saying he doesn't know
anything about it
because this is the old one
no that's not it
or it's this one here
so here watch this Hassan and you don't
have to say anything but I have to pee
but I do want to see this yeah so so
people are going yo why after this
Crusade they went on against you and
Pokey for not reacting hard enough right
and saying you don't care about victims
while deflecting against their gambling
Scandal watch this
I I don't know anybody it is I generally
I didn't have to say any of this I can't
I can't talk about it
I generally
I gently did not look into it
like I don't know I don't know what you
want for me
I did not look into that I know nothing
about it therefore I will say no
judgment and I will not make a sentence
that's the thing that I don't know
he knows nothing about train wreck and
alinity right yet if you go back in 2019
he sure seems to to acknowledge uh
here's train talking about how much he
hates salinity cat in my life I've never
had a cat in my life dude
because of the whole false accusation
thing dude I'm just sitting here
reaching toward anything I can wait what
is the cheesy cheesy means I'm just
[ __ ] around I I I'm milking it I'm
just I'm trying to milk it as much as I
can see where the [ __ ] you want dude
I'm this is this is Heaven for you
what'd you say I know what you're saying
it's awesome you don't want like a Witch
Hunt do you want us to be like say what
we think about the situation but not be
like hey you better do something well
because I like having twitch some switch
stuff are very cool right and I really
like enjoy that I mean I'm sure it's
trying to have that also right just
don't touch other than chat I'm pretty
sure yeah did I miss it
yeah it was really just him bringing it
up in uh XC acknowledging he was like oh
okay yeah yeah yeah easy means I'm just
[ __ ] around I
I'm milking it I'm
wait where was it was it back or here it
was right at the beginning
reaching toward anything I can
I've never had a camera it burns
people's brains man
I'm cheesing because of the whole false
accusation thing dude I'm just sitting
here reaching toward anything I can he
knows exactly what he's talking about he
goes it's the false accusation thing he
goes okay
[ __ ] it's a small moment but
he's obviously lying about not knowing
anything about it so you know
um wait he defends it he says actually
claims the interaction between elinity
and transmutual hold on I gotta pee by
the way I'll be back
this song is going to the bathroom what
is this a new one uh maybe yeah XC
claims that Pokemon and other streamers
are Cloud chasing
through their uh gambling
stance that you shouldn't be able to
play
uh with unregulated crypto casinos in a
Shack in carousel
foreign
mostly yeah because I guarantee you
I guarantee you there is not a singular
person who's ugly against Gamba
who have a massive impact and reach on
Twitch who have contacts and twitch
staff and higher-ups they can send a
text to or they're going to DM to or
they can literally just call on the
[ __ ] phone right not a singular one
of them not one
that's insane I don't know I'm sure
that's not true yeah
as a side note I'm having the time of my
life in your Tick Tock chat oh you in
there battling I am just pissing them
off I'm just saying W Ethan Alpha Ethan
beta they're going back and forth with
me I'm having so much fun then I'm going
to their account seeing how many
followers they have and then being like
50 follower beta oh what's up all the
betas there's 50 followers guys I'll be
your daddy
I'm here I'm better I'll teach you how
to [ __ ] or I mean listen
I hate women you know what I'm saying
I'll say whatever you want I think that
women should be in the kitchen whatever
yada yada yada men should exercise and
have big muscles come here come join us
women be shopping guys come on
uh so here he's making a pretty
interesting allegation against you uh
son
here I'll play it for you I'll play from
the top
he's saying you're clout chasing but uh
the the the the evidence is interesting
oh yeah mostly yeah
wait why am I because yeah I guarantee
you
I guarantee you there is not a singular
person who's ugly against Gamba
who have a massive impact and reach on
Twitch who have contacts and twitch
staff and higher-ups they can send a
text to or they're going to DM to you or
they can really just call on the [ __ ]
phone right not a singular one of them
not one made any contact or effort to
get things moving behind the scenes wait
he's wrong of course wrong of course
he's totally wrong he's just a [ __ ]
lying we literally all gave statements
to to uh to to which Executives 100 not
according to him he guarantees wait that
all of you never reached out dude why
would wait this is what I don't
understand these are things I've said
publicly why the [ __ ] would I not say
them again
uh to to someone in a position of power
this is a legitimate this is a
legitimate anger and a this is something
that like legitimately bothered me
especially with like no [ __ ]
safeguards whatsoever on like the crypto
steak.com gambling websites it's just
like he's a [ __ ] liar it's so silly
to make that assertion he's just him and
train are both bad face bad faith
[ __ ] outright Liars manipulated by
the way like even after all that I still
thought like there's a high likelihood
that twitch won't do it because yeah I
mean they were they were dragging their
feet for so long yeah that's I mean he's
not even that's so stupid what because
he's just lying the audience but like
that's the type of [ __ ] that here's the
thing that's the type of [ __ ] that's
like so easily dismissable because like
people even in his audience are probably
gonna go why the [ __ ] wouldn't they do
that if they've already talked about it
openly I doubt it it's like a Donald
Trump lie you know what I mean
like why why you know why wouldn't I do
that yeah right
not a singular one of them not one
made any contact or effort to get things
moving behind the scenes or publicly
until there's a wave of a [ __ ] Slicker
[ __ ] scam [ __ ] Gamba for them to hop on
the horse and go with their hashtags
what's the funniest that's the funniest
part about this I actually cared he says
like buddy he says no one cared until
like soccer but give me one proof of
anybody try to make anything move so
prove to him that you actually cared us
on the only person that really cares
is him and trained because they make
millions of dollars every month no
that's that's really weird that is
really [ __ ] weird what a weird thing
to say
because like we openly talked about it
in public too uh not only do we openly
talk about it in public
but I'm pretty sure like uh okay so so
misgift definitely talked to Executives
directly uh about this issue
and
um not only that but
what was I going to say [ __ ] I'm like
losing my trend of thought here so it's
such an oblivious it's such a ridiculous
taste you're saying Ms Kiff was writing
to but you guys were all of course of
course he's just a liar bro we'll be
talking about it that's insane but the
notion that like we did it exclusively
after the Slicker thing is so silly
because
you and I have had a very public debate
about the morality of gambling
especially centered around stake.com and
crypto online casinos and how [ __ ]
awful that is a year prior to this yeah
we very publicly had this conversation
so much so that even trained was like if
you guys like it so much why don't you
start a [ __ ] podcast which is like I
actually have that clip in here moment
of training we are training [ __ ] that
is how left over started wait hold on
hold on shouts out the train wrecks for
that uh for this you know what this is
such a beautiful full circle moment I
have this clip here here we are about a
year ago talking about the same [ __ ]
thing with train wreck uh and and and uh
here it is
that argument isn't fair because
if you're gonna give me that argument
then I need you guys to put together a
podcast and be this [ __ ] hyper
focused on gambling as you or or this
hyper focused on drinking and that's
this wouldn't [ __ ] happen and now
we're talking about his dumbass oh my
God train wrecks TV is the [ __ ]
reason why the leftovers podcast
happened oh my God here we are train
your worst [ __ ] nightmare [ __ ] it's
just so funny leftovers oh yeah and Don
Jr of course uh yeah our maiden voyage
yeah
here's po go ahead no I just I think
it's like uh it's it's a silly [ __ ]
it's such a silly thing to say when
there is so much evidence to prove you
wrong I don't understand like dude just
log off brother just [ __ ] take a
shower you know go to sleep try to sleep
as long as you can and then and then you
know take another
take another go at it because like
you won't talk about liars
here's my guarantee to uh xqc
him and train wreck are always going on
about like yo I play Slots for Love of
the Game when I'm not streaming I'm
playing slots because I just love it
though and I'm addicted to it well
here's my guarantee that when that
sponsor money runs out in October let's
see how much these guys are still
playing on stake after that no they
won't they definitely will I know they
will not yes they will they're going to
be broke by the end of the month if they
know family like that they have too much
money they're not gonna be broke well
that's crazy okay let's see I don't
think they will I think I think the only
thing that steak.com being banned off of
the platform does for X you see is I
mean it takes a like tens of millions of
dollars out of his pocket certainly
um probably puts tens of millions of
dollars back into his pocket because he
can't gamble for the five [ __ ] hours
that he would be gambling on stream
anyway that's it but he will definitely
gamble off stream I don't think so I
think they're gonna take the bag and
call it a day
I think they only say that so that they
can look more like so they have this
veneer no no they're like yo this is
just what I do in my free time so all
I'm doing is streaming what I love to do
it's [ __ ] I'm shocked I think he's I
think they are I think they are
definitely degenerates they're not going
to be anyway here's Pokey saying how she
uh talked to Executives about it
so he was
collecting little
vouches essentially from all sorts of
streamers who wanted to get gambling
banned off of the site to essentially
then show the twitch and show them like
hey this is something we care about and
feel strongly about it's awesome that
was four days ago XC is a [ __ ] liar
uh and he's a piece of [ __ ] what is
wrong with you [ __ ] I think here here's
what I think I think he is he's uh
he's like desperately slinging for
anyone and anything that he can
yeah that's not cool what he's saying no
it's not it's it's anyone else would be
like probably blowing up on him way
harder than I have thus far
but I just wanna like I said I don't
want to dilute the the conversation
however
um
what he's doing is is like I've been
thinking about this a lot I've been
thinking about what what he's been doing
like does this have actual staying power
okay because I'm sorry because he has
such a large audience who love him who
uh believe everything he says I wonder
like regardless of how very clearly this
is untrue like a lot of the things that
he says including like I doubt it these
[ __ ] went to the [ __ ]
Executives you know what I mean like
[ __ ] like that that is demonstrably that
guarantee you he didn't say I doubt he
says I guarantee yeah okay
um or or even like oh you were
dismissive you were dismissive like when
your original uh react in your original
reaction you really undermined like our
cause here when like train wrecks
delivery was actually undermining uh if
we're gonna be real about it
um like I I wonder if it doesn't matter
for a lot of people and they still go
yeah [ __ ] this guy and and you know he
is a piece of [ __ ] of course it doesn't
matter keemstar still has fans I mean if
that's proof to you that nobody cares
about anything nothing yeah I don't know
not many though not many I'm I I guess
when I think about [ __ ] like that dude
it's just [ __ ] makes me upset
um here is uh xqc accusing you of not
reacting hard enough to the news
it's not neutral what is going on here
these clouds these clouds everything and
the severity of the situation this is so
disgusting we're having a conversation
over who is [ __ ] we're having a copy
he's a [ __ ] I saw the
clipboard like me not reacting hard
enough to the information or whatever
because your soul conversation
a main subject is something that you
[ __ ] popcorn Emoji to okay which is
sexual assault I am going to treat it in
the severity that it [ __ ] deserves
you can immediately rush to conclusions
okay
I mean you both know that that that the
seed idea is very important when
something is fresh and you created a
seed of doubt in that initial thing okay
and then he refused to enter and he
refused to watch the rest of the clip
that was a clip chimp clip like that was
shortened yeah uh where I straight up
I'm like I don't know either of these
people I don't know what's going on it
might be about this crazy slick is a
[ __ ] weirdo so uh if that is about
that like I don't know but I need more
uh information before I talk about it
remember what he said and now let's jump
to here when it's about his friend
I
I generally I
did right I don't know why I generally
crazy
I mean look I'm good at the time about
it no I'm just saying like that if I was
a dick I'd be like yeah man real nice
real nice of you to [ __ ] be so
dismissive uh when it's uh your friend
or whatever but like it's the it's a
buyer logic argument which is like you
know I guess he's doing the appropriate
thing in that circumstance which is uh
waiting for more information but it
seems like when he got more information
he just said that like what did he say
he said it was reciprocated she was
flirting back with him it was a lie she
doesn't she like if you if you say
believe her she know she doesn't say
they're flirting by the way here's train
wreck also spreading [ __ ] uh
extremely misogynistic disgusting lies
about alinity later on uh in 2019.
anyways dude I fully agree with you dude
and I hate to say it but I'm gonna say
it dude
and honest to God believe everything
Greek is saying [ __ ] I think I honestly
think that olinity has something
on someone that has decent power in on
Twitch
or has [ __ ] them either [ __ ] them or
as decent power or something over them
that that has decent power it has to be
the case I've never seen someone I mean
it's not even the case it's not it's not
even the case where it's hello I'm Knute
I'm from Norway you told me to
it's not even the case where
mistakes are happening and the person's
apologetic about it like something like
this happens and they
and she's gloating about it like there's
a smirk on her face this whole thing
about her gloating was just so made up
lips man and by the way this is such a
malicious [ __ ] up lie he's a piece of
[ __ ] this is a continuation of his
sexual harassment of her in my opinion
saying that oh she's definitely [ __ ]
someone at twitch that's the only
explanation for what's going on of
course no evidence it's not true
um
and uh there it is and by the way if
anyone's uh [ __ ] or or bribing
employees at twitch having influence of
people at twitch let's call back train
one more time here I think we're good
let's get back to this if anyone if
there's evidence of anyone influencing
twitch employees
here's one guy I know right Hassan
I mean
I maintained a position at like high
level or regular regulation people that
like are in charge of banning are not
people that have a is that you want two
staff accounts dude you can't get money
that's which implies no no I mean he's
doing that 100
look you know what that is that's a huge
PR [ __ ] up for twitch that's why they
banned gambling that definitely probably
like I suspect that that is uh that
played a reason with them you know
moving forward with it as quickly as
possible that's what I'm saying bro
larger PR uh move for them was to just
like get a dub out of this gambling
thing
um here he is sending fifteen thousand
dollars to him employee got him we got
him one of the wildest Parts about this
is like the amounts of money that we're
talking about that are so [ __ ] like
insane you know gigantic here's 50 000.
oh it's cute you never had fifty
thousand dollars before here is I'm just
saying he's a [ __ ] hypocrite and a
liar he accuses her of influencing
twitch staff by [ __ ] them super
misogynistic and disgusting and here he
is giving them money on camera boom
roasted get the [ __ ] out train wreck
[ __ ] no there is even without even
without additional context there's
significantly more evidence that you
could uh that you could point to with
respect to like you know bribing twitch
stuff even if it wasn't meant to be a
bribe it doesn't even matter there is
more evidence of Train giving money to
Twitch uh there it is than there is a
validity having sex with a twitch staff
there's no evidence that's just pure
misogynistic disgusting [ __ ] but there
it is that's it that's all I have to say
about that train uh [ __ ] you xqc you are
such a piece of [ __ ] and uh sorry that
the bag is lost guys but you'll get over
it
all right well they're pretty
comfortable there so we'll see
uh by the way I I want to talk about
this this is important and a lot of
people in the chat are actually talking
about it I don't know if there's
Iranians in the chat is that I thought
they turned off the internet there
but this is super sporadically turn it
on and off this is super interesting uh
in Iran right now uh there was a young
activist woman who was killed uh and for
not wearing like a hijab she was killed
in prison and there's like massive uh
protests going on in Iran men and women
burning hijabs I saw they stormed up
police station this is [ __ ] awesome
Masa amini is the name of uh I believe
she's 22
um uh who died in police custody after
the morality police the the Sharia
police basically
um beat her and and she was declared
brain dead by the time she had gone to
the hospital there are photos of all of
that and it's it's really gruesome it's
awful
um
and and now it has uh created it sparked
a nationwide outrage protests everywhere
uh with with women and men all around
Iran uh protesting the streets taking it
up the streets the government itself
actually had to say like oh she's like
my own daughter we are going to really
hate this yeah I mean it's like you know
[ __ ] PR but but that's I I mean I'm
impressed that they even were like
pretending it's a combination of
multiple factors obviously it's it is a
uh you know authoritarian nightmare yeah
that uh is is uh Theocratic and and
really really a fundamentalist
um and on top of that uh you know there
is so much economic instability
volatility caused by uh the the Iranian
denuclearization agreement which like
Iran was following on that Donald Trump
decided to throw aside shut up and then
add additional sanctions to and Biden
has kind of like continued that uh
strategy like Iran is in a state of
disarray that's why you put sanctions on
a country so they like literally have uh
you know anything and everything that uh
frustrates enough people to turn into
massive protests and it's and it's
currently happening
um having said that of course the the
fundamentalist islamist government is is
horrifying to live under uh definitely
not a fan of that these people are so
brave like you know what I mean like
[ __ ] people this is real protest you
know what I mean like in the face of a
tyrannical government that can just kill
you or put you away for life these
people are going out there not covering
their face and this is some real [ __ ]
this is real bravery what's going on
there it's incredible to see
good for them but I hope it works out
for them they don't all get crushed too
I mean but I guess well the government
is going to do everything it can to
suppress it
um and also you know you're seeing that
already people are getting beaten up and
locked into Vans and the reality is like
I mean we even do this in America and
America does not have the same like
control over as wide a population as
Iran does you know what I mean it's just
uh it's just authoritarian government
[ __ ] it's really [ __ ] up yeah I'd love
to see like a
a prospering beautiful free Iran or
secular Iran that would be just amazing
you know I hear such a beautiful country
too and it's just
oh it's just such a shame that
they've just been [ __ ]
taken over by these Democratic don't try
to nationalize your oil extraction
industry you know what I'm saying I
won't big you know don't do it
I was thinking about it in 1953 because
we're coming for you the British Empire
is coming for you that's British
Petroleum uh oil refineries that's their
assets
and they'll do anything and everything
they can
well good luck we love you
and uh if you know what go get them
tigers
right yeah hey you want to do um
the Republicans are trying to get uh
doctors killed or do you want to do uh
DeSantis kidnapping um your choice I
mean I I I've talked about both so I
actually need to go to the bathroom
okay we can start with the Santa's
kidnapping Myers one hold on you gotta
you want to start you can get started I
can just give like background
information
okay
um for those of you don't know last week
Ron DeSantis the governor of Florida
sent 50 Asylum Seekers that were coming
into the state of Texas not Florida
okay Ron DeSantis the governor of
Florida he's Venezuelan Asylum Seekers
who have every legal right to seek
asylum on U.S soil uh were inside of the
State of Texas he took them flew them
out from Texas to Martha's Vineyard in
Massachusetts he did this because he's a
clout Goblin he's a clout demon he's a
clout shark and he saw that this was
what the governor of Texas was doing and
he wanted to take a piece of that action
he wanted to get in on it because human
lives are disposable to pieces of [ __ ]
like Ron DeSantis so he flew them out
um the records show that the State of
Florida paid a little more than six
hundred thousand dollars for what has
been described as the relocation of
unauthorized aliens he lied to them and
said that there were job opportunities
in homes and housing uh in uh in
Martha's Vineyard when uh there was no
connection made to any like immigration
officers uh anyone that would be
responsibly in charge of relocating
these migrants in Martha Vineyard or in
Massachusetts the only people that were
contacted I believe at least the ones
that were contacted that were sent over
to Kamala Harris's house by
at the time people thought it was Rhonda
Sanders but I think it was governor Greg
Abbott were Fox news reporters
so just to understand uh where their
intentions are or what their intentions
are with the relocation even though Ron
DeSantis said well we're making it their
problem now this is going to be a blue
State problem uh it's it's time that uh
you know we we take the the burden away
from the red States the burden of
migrants from the red States and handed
off the blue States now of course if you
know anything about immigration into the
United States both undocumented and
documented you would know that migrants
are not exactly a stress on the American
welfare state which is virtually
non-existent but uh but instead uh
genuinely the backbone of our economy
they are brutalized in horrific work
conditions but they certainly put more
into the economy than they take out
um so that's already [ __ ]
it's additionally [ __ ] to imply that
red states are the only states that are
shouldering the entirety of the burden
of migrants even though there is no real
burden when California is [ __ ] right
there okay all right that's another
state with a fat border okay that is
insane
um so that's additionally ridiculous uh
what's also ridiculous is that Rhonda
Sanchez himself has come out numerous
times and said well you know we only
have like one or two Venezuelans coming
into Florida so we couldn't have enough
Venezuelans coming into Florida to ship
them out to make this publicity stunt so
that's why he went to Texas to do it now
there's a criminal probe uh from a Texas
Sheriff that has been launched against
Ronda Sands because this is considered
you know trafficking and miners as well
there are little babies that were on
this uh that were that were involved in
all of this and uh all of these people
most of these people have court dates
uh because you know 98 or 99 of
undocumented immigrants that are legally
seeking asylum in the United States have
court dates that they return to however
this has made it additionally harder for
them to return to said court dates
considering that they just kind of
shipped them off to Martha's Vineyard if
you have a court date in San Antonio and
now you're in [ __ ] Martha's Vineyard
how the hell are you going to make it
back to your court date none of these uh
none of these migrants were informed
about any of this process and they were
used and abused as political pawns as
disposable political pawns because of
their undocumented status regardless of
the fact that the United States
government has no diplomatic
relationship with Venezuela therefore
there is no deportation protocol for
Venezuelans and they have temporary
protected status all the way until I
believe 2024 which means that
well I personally believe all
undocumented immigrants that are coming
into this country whether they're
economic refugees whether they're
refugees because they're fleeing
domestic violence whether they're
refugees because they're fleeing
terrorism or anything like that or a
narco state it doesn't matter I believe
that they all should have temporary
protected status and a means to become
natural uh you know naturalized U.S
citizens
um Venezuelans given America's interest
in uh you know destroying communism have
additional protections on top of that
not only that but also Ron DeSantis
doing this is a really weird considering
that there is a gigantic anti-communist
Venezuelan population in [ __ ] Florida
just like there is a large very sizable
uh Cuban population in Florida so
um really weird stuff for Miranda Santos
instead of relocating Venezuelans into
an area where there are already a lot of
Venezuelans who have immigrated into the
United States he thought he would send
them to Martha's Vineyard or Greg Abbott
sending them to DC and New York as well
yes so
I'm just first of all did you mention
that he spent six hundred thousand
dollars of Florida Floridian taxpayer
money to fly them there I'm a little bit
confused on his end at the end game
there because he flew these
immigrants
to Martha's Vineyard Massachusetts
and basically just pieced out spent six
hundred thousand dollars to drop off 50
immigrants and they weren't even in men
women and children they were in Texas
so like I just don't understand like
even if it's political theater I don't
quite understand what it is they're
trying to say with this
oh he was just trying to say like blue
States should shoulder the burden now
not us but like it wasn't even they
weren't even coming into Florida they
were in Texas right right so like you
literally so clearly inserted yourself
into this you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
because you just wanted some political
clout out of this
and Fox News of course is like happy to
give it to him yes so well what was
funny to me I feel like they were gonna
their intention was to be like we're
gonna drop them off there and then you
guys deal with them you're gonna Deport
them you'll see like you know used to
call us like uh xenophobic and we're
deporting immigrants you guys can do the
same thing
so they tried to build this narrative
that uh Martha's vineya Massachusetts is
a bunch of xenophobes uh here's one big
clip uh this I don't know who clay
Travis is but I'm sure he's a [ __ ]
demon
uh he said Martha's Vineyard
couldn't handle 15 illegal immigrants
for even 24 out 50 illegal immigrants
for even 24 hours they called in buses
and deported them from the island but I
thought left Wingers loved diversity a
sad day this has 50 000 likes
2.3 million views it's actually pretty
incredible yeah because if you look on
the map obviously Martha's vineyard's a
tiny place there's not a lot of space
that what they call deporting them
a sad day for liberals they literally
just is a one and a half hour bus ride
to where they can help house them you
know the ironies that like white
supremacist segregationists did this
exact same [ __ ] uh political move uh
during the Civil Rights era where they
called him uh reverse Freedom Rides
where they would uh tell black people uh
that you know there were job
opportunities in housing like free
housing that they were going to get in
uh in Martha's Vineyard
um because it's just seen as like a like
an area where like Rich liberals live
you know what I mean it's true there's a
lot of Rich lives that live there like
Obama has a house there you know what I
mean uh that sort of thing
um and of course they they were uh in an
effort to find adequate Housing Shelter
and job opportunities for everyone that
was shipped back then they were also uh
sent over to the uh Joint Base Cape Cod
uh back then as well so same exactly
repeats itself over and over again
because white supremacy in America is a
is a foundational part of American uh
experience yeah I mean they're just such
[ __ ] Liars again and what the irony
is that is they're like watch you guys
support them they send them an hour and
a half to the space where they could
comfortably house them they they're all
hooked up with attorneys they're all
hooked up with like um
security food shelter the only thing
they really achieved
is that these guys all have good
representation now and I'm pretty sure
they're all going to get there's a class
action lawsuit yeah as well so one of
the things I I always talk about with
respect to immigration is that like yeah
if you want to relocate migrants okay
consent is obviously the key factor here
but if you want to relocate migrants
into other parts of the country that is
fine that's like there are better places
if you truly do not have the capacity to
take care of all the migrants that are
coming in into Texas which Texas
certainly does uh and and there are
definitely plenty of industries that uh
are absolutely taking advantage of that
situation to further exploit these
people uh and and create like a
permanent underclass that you can easily
dispose of and then bring in new people
as like Purdue has done time and time
again the chicken manufacturers in the
agricultural industry like you know
migrant uh migrant workers are the
backbone of of American Agriculture and
food production in general so
um they certainly have enough to to help
everyone but they refuse to do so
because they're reactionary Psychopaths
but even if relocation was a possibility
and plenty of migrants would like to
happily go like uh the ones that uh Greg
Abbott was again sending as a political
tool in a political prop to places like
DC and then like basically bussing them
to the White House like it's just so
disgusting and disingenuous but one way
to do that one way to do such relocation
would be to again
have immigration Specialists have
translators and lawyers in every step of
the process and and uh you know send
people that want to go to different
places and then inform those places
ahead of time so there is adequate
protection for these people instead of
like giving them one meal in the morning
and then sending their uh you know
shipping them off like their disposable
trash uh over to a different state after
lying to them it's it's so it's so
deeply disturbing but of course we have
no Humanity like we have no way of
seeing the humanity of undocumented
immigrants well I mean again it really
just it is disturbing because it shows
how he really doesn't even see them as
human not worthy of any human dignity to
lie to families of people men women and
children lie to them get them on a plane
and drop them in of some [ __ ] random
spot and then peace out I mean it's the
man's a demon I mean uh what a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] he is did you read this
part yet on the plam flip no yeah so on
the pamphlet this is the fake pamphlet
they handed out to them to get them on
the plane they go reception and
placement service
during the first 90 days after a refugee
arrives in Massachusetts three
settlement agencies provide basic needs
and support including assistance with
housing Furnishing food basic
necessities clothing transportation to
job interviews job training assistance
and applying for social security card
registering children for school using
public transportation facilities and
services community and cultural
orientation that they just straight up
lied about isn't that sad though because
like that's something I wish that was
the [ __ ] case like that is literally
what a normal country would do and not
just like uh you know a bunch of
corporations in a [ __ ] trench coat
like the United States of America is uh
run by a bunch of charlatans like that
is what a normal country would do in
this circumstance they would communicate
there would be interested communication
right uh there would be resettlement
programs readily available that is
funded by the federal government and
there are some resettlement programs
that are funded they're obviously
underfunded severely
but they made no effort to even trigger
any of this because their entire purpose
was to again and I cannot stress this
enough use these people who uh simply
had The Misfortune of Being Born into a
state of disarray
that we're looking for uh you know a
better means of of survival in the
United States of America
the thought that you know
these people would treat them like human
beings
and they showed once again that they
were not interested in doing that the
Republicans showed once again they're
not interested in doing that at all and
and use them as political tools but the
thing that really gets me is like yeah
these people were all going through the
correct legal process they weren't like
yeah they weren't like uh you know
criminals they weren't like uh as many
do by the way like that's yeah that is
the reality for so many uh Asylum
Seekers is that of course they're not uh
gonna [ __ ] anything up and that's also
precisely the reason why undocumented
immigrants are are responsible for a
smaller percentage of crime per capita
than Natural Born U.S citizens are
that's the other you know reality
uh it's it's pretty crazy and then if
you look at the the pamphlet also just
to prove what [ __ ] morons they are
um
they didn't even use the right state
flag so
they I don't know where the [ __ ] they
got this this is not the Massachusetts
state flag it actually doesn't even look
anything like it oh I have where they
got it from
it was just some random like blog wasn't
it there's some rant this random Imgur
album was somebody experimenting
not officially or anything I just think
the current flag blows so I made one
featuring the state flower and they used
that one I think they just went to
Google images and type Massachusetts
flag and does that come up if you do
that though that's a good question
because like does not like how the [ __ ]
did they get this triggering dude
cam is from Massachusetts so this is a
very upsetting they have like a Native
American on there right yeah but I think
they're changing it now actually so
maybe they'll change it to this flower
design yeah what do you think this is in
the Runnings for sure
uh here
what'd you think
yeah I could live with that I guess okay
I miss I like the yellow on our current
flag though so the center flower kind of
looks like Howie Mandel might make a
tick tock about it a little butthole ow
ow what are you gonna do about it so
there you go uh surprise surprise
DeSantis and Abbott are [ __ ] demons
who uh do not even View
immigrants as uh people
worthy of any the slightest dignity at
all
I type Massachusetts flag is is the real
flag all the way down yeah on the Google
Images so I'm no [ __ ] clue how they
got that or even why would they use a
fake flag like for what I mean they must
have intentionally thought that out I
assumed it was just buffoonery but how
yeah I don't know how I don't I don't
have a good expert there's no way
yeah but anyway
um the other main story I want to talk
about is just that uh
train wreck is a giant piece of [ __ ] no
I'm just kidding uh hogwatch it would be
Republicans are trying to kill doctors
do we have time to get into this Dan
um
questionable
depends on how quickly you get through
it we could just watch oh yeah all these
rappers yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
a couple of months of old white rappers
trying to get in office have you seen
these on yes
uh I love this this is incredible is she
gonna win how's she pulling do we know
no I have no idea look but if she's if
she's not getting 100 of the vote if
she's getting 99 of the vote Utah is
cooked yeah because they do not
appreciate true art well here it is this
is the new face of Maga uh ladies and
gentlemen
bump it Zach
12. listen up right here there's a new
name on the ballot for the Senate this
year okay
Republican and awesome love God and
family and the Constitution let's go try
to get another conservative to rent
nobody could do it so you couldn't find
a better photo than that what the [ __ ]
failed on
okay I take it back this rocks they're
pro-life
the right to bear arms and the right to
free speech okay less government
political corruption
quality morality government programs
should lead to self-sufficiency and
support traditional family as the
fundamental unit of society but in
schools they are pushing for new beliefs
and Justice female adult I know what a
woman is
she just gave up all rhyming schemes at
the end there it dropped that truth bomb
push it for new beliefs and just to
clarify female adult I know what a woman
is Burns let's go yup bump bump hey E-40
do I know what a what a woman is
nope
all right yeah so how's she pulling Dan
I'm not finding anything I think there's
way too like small of an election to him
damn wow I want her to win everyone's a
liberal out here they're just afraid of
the truth
and then here's another one uh this is
from 2018 but they have somehow a track
record oh we can't use that that one's
copyrighted yep but there's another one
uh you you shut that down so quick yeah
okay I'm good with that man YouTube
streaming man they gotta figure that out
so here's another guy uh this guy's name
is uh the juice his last name is the
juice key isn't that right wait majooski
wait wait wait what's up my juice is the
[ __ ] guy who like is famous for
having like the fattest
Trump mural in his front yard or
something oh I don't know about that I
know that he's famous for lying about
his military service what's his name
good guy uh J.R Majewski his name is he
like bro I don't know that feels like
this guy what's up majooski add me up
I'm just I don't know bro I know that
guy ain't no Jill I'll tell you that
right now
yeah they don't give a [ __ ] let's be
real yeah I was like aren't
conservatives against Stolen Valor oh my
God it is him oh my God oh my God it's
gonna blow your [ __ ] mind dude pull
it up
God damn this [ __ ] is so far God I know
my [ __ ] freaks man who painted
Trump's face so long could be headed to
Congress brother I know my [ __ ]
freaks dude okay it isn't in this
article though no the one it's in the
article I sent you oh there you go it's
an article I said you you need to pull
this up right now
yo oh my God actually impressive though
he got so much divorce mom [ __ ] with
this dude
every Barbara from Toledo all the way
down to Akron was like I'm so wet when I
see your Trump mural wait though damn
but wait that's actually super
impressive the whole size of that God
damn it Clinton never seen no [ __ ]
mirror like this before this are not are
not mobilizing like this what are you
doing on your [ __ ] backyard that's
what I'm saying dude you got nothing I
got nothing I can't even show my love
for Trump like this ever if I even
wanted to
oh he here's an update he updated it
Trump 2022. oh that's kind of whack yeah
I liked his face better
69.
how do you even do that
also the boat the boat right there oh
God I love Ohio so much what a wonderful
he's actually talented that's a nice
detail I can't take it away from him
white boy
so there it is so this is him okay good
context so he's headed to Congress guys
here he is
no can force us to get the Vex taking
pictures with the probe will get us to
overlap not to [ __ ] for fun and dementia
it's a serious disease
squeeze your cheeks when you sneeze
squeeze your cheeks when you sneeze I
don't know what that means but
um
I'd like to unpack that with you the
juice clap those cheeks so ice cream
while he's crapping his pants we want
our dreams and our freedom this is the
most polish man in America
like there is no man that is more polish
than this thing so Majewski oh yeah that
sounds polish he's not Jewish is he
[Music]
um
looks like he's half uh he is he is uh a
cab assigned cop at Birth
it looks like his mom his uh dad was a
redneck and his mom was a [ __ ]
literal Pig yeah I know he [ __ ] a pig
his dad [ __ ] a pig he is the
personification of a potato like he is
like if a potato became sentient yeah
he's polish uh yeah I'm saying it's just
a common polish last name surname yeah
kind of sucks though I'm saying
the Jews yeah I don't know times are
weird does keemstar have to say about
that I don't know what do you think of
Majewski got to all Jews oh no bro come
on Keem what the [ __ ] he's a candidate
he's a politician
you better stop that yeah I think
keemstar's uh surname would be uh my
death to all juice peas oh my God
again he's doing it again Ethan you just
stop him I can't what can I do it's
going crazy
funny yeah that is literally a hill that
so many died on
right it's always it's always hilarious
when [ __ ] are like Hassan and
Ethan are so unsympathetic to the plight
of millions of Americans who died to
covet it's like no man we very clearly
said like if you want to die uh from you
know a preventable thing that you didn't
want to take precautions against like
yeah then go ahead you know I was just
saying do your thing yeah Freedom isn't
free yeah he's like this is a hill that
will die yeah yeah he meant heart
disease
uh United uh divided we follow united we
stand
was Abraham Lincoln right that was him
he wasn't very he was very divisive
I think he just didn't want to debate
those slavers is [ __ ] up well he did
literally but you know it didn't work
out and then what did he do that's
[ __ ] up this is the kind of [ __ ]
guy be flying a Confederate flag I'm
just saying
yeah that's always wonderful when people
from Ohio fly the Confederate flag it's
just like it's so obvious what that's
about at that point it's like you don't
understand your own history
oh that's a Winston Churchill on all
right Winston Churchill also divisive
also divisive Nazis hated him yeah he
did not want to debate them
why couldn't we why couldn't everybody
hear him out you know what I'm saying
like that's [ __ ] up he didn't have
enough uh you know he didn't have enough
Sympathy for the Nazis it's just wasn't
sure who didn't have a lot of sympathy
for anybody really I mean it wasn't just
the Nazis and definitely definitely
Indian people I was about to say he
treated all Indian people this the same
yeah he was not he was not exactly
well the same yeah I mean the bar was
pretty low oh all bad okay I got it I
thought you were just talking about
equality
um but we got to keep keep these bars
going yeah
right
they all look like they're they all look
like [ __ ] 20 pounds of sausages fit
into a 10 pound bag dude oh no why did
he found Assad's backyard he's got my
vote dude this is Hassan's backyard we
found it
[Applause]
dude that's right it's obscene you draw
that in your backyard it's not a [ __ ] no
that's it I I drew it on his front yard
yeah okay shout out cuss he's everywhere
just kidding I'd never go to Ohio get
the [ __ ] out of here we love Ohio please
we love our Hawaii plane
we need something I agree too that
and don't agree to that uh anyway let's
see talk I mean oh [ __ ] there's the
Tucker one
yeah I don't know what do you think how
long we've been going we don't have any
time left it's 12. it's 12. yeah
anything uh basically in short I want to
say hey the tater tots didn't get us off
Tick Tock yet tater tots what's up I'm
your daddy now I'll lead you dude trust
me I know all kinds of stuff about being
a man and I will teach you also women
are lame right it's on hell yeah man
women suck I love Bugattis they've been
two years that's why they haven't banned
you yet yo I just women freaking are
lame dude
I hear they drool dude they do all you
guys women drooled yeah that's right
come over here I'll tell you guys all
about it on YouTube join us
you're [ __ ] drooling over there well
I'm glad we're back we're back baby way
better than ever
anything you want to say to the people
um not really I'm just I'm Gonna Be Live
soon uh going straight home going live
always nice yeah what's on the docket do
it live
um the the definitely the conservatives
are trying to murder uh doctor's thing
uh I'll probably address some of the
additional uh stuff that uh came out on
on like the twitch platform drama
there's also the whole like uh
hundreds of thousands of children have
been or you know
there are predators on the platform
there's a new Bloomberg investigation
yeah
it doesn't surprise me I just haven't
seen the yeah I mean they're everywhere
I mean YouTube had its own share of that
obviously if as you recall as you
remember it's like so hard to [ __ ]
control when it comes to uh you know
live streaming too but are there kids
live streaming though like like
sometimes really young kids sometimes
are they allowed to have to be 13 plus
to be able to be on the platform if you
say I'm 12 they will ban you immediately
okay but you don't have to like confirm
your ID or something
so what's oh here's the article I'm just
really curious about the but YouTube
actually had a good solution they turned
off comments for all
children's videos now which is I think a
good thing like yeah and nobody
spreading any good conversation in those
comment sections anyway child Predators
use twitch to systematically track kids
live streaming what
yeah what yeah
you're tracking them
yeah predatory accounts what the [ __ ]
what this whole I read this article last
night uh the web design on it is uh Next
Level immaculate yeah it's crazy we we
are thinking why are we in like
something they know but we're like in
the space of this is a big bang of child
and this time at least
1976 users systematically found and
followed young people recording
themselves live on the site according to
Twitch profile data screenshots
twitch is having the worst week of its
life dude why don't you take a seat
right over there yeah look at this where
I'm in outer space of child grooming
this is exciting these are these alleged
Predators targeted 20 2007 279 000
children what
each had more than a thousand kids and
they're following list Jesus Christ bro
put them in a [ __ ] put him in an
asylum immediately what the [ __ ] and
I've Loved kids there was something
kind of like this on YouTube yeah that
led to what you're talking where they
like really locked down all the kids
stuff yeah well there was like basically
it was super nasty like you would go to
um
videos with young girls or boys whatever
and they would they would be sharing
time stamps of when you could see like
their underwear or they were in like
what they thought was right suggestive
situations they're like um yummy clicked
it it was [ __ ] my rehabilitative
approach to criminal justice is is
shaking right now it is very like it's
it's on its last [ __ ] shrimp when I
hear stuff like this
oh twitch grew a lot during the pen yeah
41 I think wow yeah I like to see why
they're giving pay cuts did your channel
grow a lot during that time yeah bro I
went from I went full time in the
beginning of 2020 because I knew like
you know the Chinese government told me
that covet was happening ahead of time
yeah that's parody by the way I don't
want to [ __ ] I don't want to [ __ ]
your [ __ ] up no it's not you told me off
screen though okay well anyway I knew
that that was happening so I was like
I'm going full full time on Twitch so it
was a combination of those two things
together but yes I grew up I guess I
forget how long ago in the beginning of
2020. yeah in the beginning of 2020
before I went full time on Twitter I was
like averaging 5K really by the end of
2020 with the election cycle heating up
especially during the election I had
like 120
000 yeah that I was averaging live
concurrence something crazy like that
that's awesome and then of course it
like it went back down to normal but my
normal became 30k
by the way thank you for the gifted
bodily Integrity thank you for the
gifted Legend that's our Saudi
benefactor I believe hello hello it is
indeed well anyway
um
all right go have a good stream there
Hassan thank you everybody uh we'll be
back tomorrow what in the [ __ ] was that
leave me alone with this creepy ass web
design duh what the [ __ ] like I just
scrolling up yeah that's the very
beginning of the article I'm in space
I'm in like a schizophrenic like last
sketch from a schizophrenic you've seen
that [ __ ] the [ __ ] it's the that's a
very weird article I need to I think
it's their way of showing uh some of the
footage of the girls that were being
stalked on the side no way out showing
them within this weird no way no no
you're right though it does look like
The Descent into schizophrenia
schizophrenic artist well there it is uh
twitch having a hard time there see you
guys tomorrow for after dark Hassan
thank you a pleasure and remember as
always remember [ __ ] train wreck
that piece of [ __ ] and [ __ ] excuse me
that's not good
not good at all do you have real beef
with them are you guys like I'm confused
about your relationship with them I I uh
oh my God zooming back into me
I mean I I think that they are like
unnecessarily and unjustifiably
constantly up my ass because I speak my
mind about things that they're doing
that I think are not good yeah
and um that's it I want to like stick to
the issues
there it is stick to the issues you
[ __ ]
the Sun
all right thanks guys
um we'll see you tomorrow
this has been another uh uh super
important World altering
broadcast from the 20 billion dollar
bunker
[Music]
foreign